model chrissy teigen frau von musiker
john legend zeigt ihre kinder nackt beim
baden die kleinen hatten zuvor mit mama
gebastelt waren voll mit glitter und
mussten in die wanne genauer gesagt ins
xxl waschbecken für das video erntet
chrissi heftige kritik darf man kinder
so zeigen so was meint ihr darf man dass
dieser trend ganz klar nein natürlich
ich sehe keinen grund dafür ja und also
ich verstehe es nicht und du kannst die
kinder auch nicht fragen weil diese noch
zu jung und es wird im grunde genommen
werden die kinder die degradiert auch zu
objekten gemacht ohne dass sie selber
welche sind aber es geht ja darum dass
das eben kein dass das mittlerweile ein
rechtsfreier raum ist also auch in
social media wie das genutzt wird dass
wir wissen dass ermittlungsbehörden kaum
hinterherkommen dass wir wissen dass
pädophile sich auf diesen seiten
einschlägig sozusagen herumtreiben und
ich wäre dagegen dass sozusagen mein
kind dann zum objekt werden könnte und
das finde ich habe auch eltern eine
fürsorgepflicht es ist jetzt ein
bisschen schade im zweiteiligen weil das
glaube ich eine ganz tolle frau ist also
selbst verteilt genau aber das ist
sozusagen mit den kindern dass er dich
also das ist für mich ganz klar und mehr
gibt es dazu nicht zu sagen auch ein
bisschen zu ihrer verteidigung sagen man
sieht ja jetzt nicht viel und ich sehe
auf instagram was kleine kinder betrifft
sehr viel schlimmere sachen als das als
ich verstehe es nicht so richtig warum
man ihr den allerwertesten aufreißen
das ist jetzt so ein bisschen also es
gibt sehr viel schlimmeres verhinderte
wir sexualisieren dadurch kinder dann
oft viel mehr als sie es eigentlich sind
also ich wünsche mir manchmal die zeiten
zurück wo es ok war dass alle nackt
unter nasen rasensprenger hin und her
gelaufen sind ohne dass jemand sagte das
ist aber jetzt unpassend also das kann
man ja wallimann mache man muss es halt
nur nicht ins netz stellt und das ist
gut so bat das kann eine private halten
ja das schauen natürlich auch die
nachbarn einfach zu und selbst die sind
ja dann mit erhobenen zeigefinger und
sagen ich fühle mich jetzt hier von
wirklich also ich möchte dass es so ein
bisschen die unschuld bewahrt ich bin
voreingenommen wels chrissy teigen ist
und die wirklich cool ist das muss ich
sagen und ich fühle mich sehr viel mehr
unter druck gesetzt von diesen müttern
die ihre kinder in einem perfekten rosa
kleidchen war dass alle marokkaner oder
vor einem investierten einsetzen daran
dass 200.000 euro verdienen weil sie
drei firmen verlinken und dann sein so
sieht bei uns jeder morgen aus und ich
sitze damit würden
es gibt zum achten mal in folge und
aufgewärmte nudel und denke mir
herzlichen dank dass ich mich wegen sie
jetzt auch noch schlecht fühlen du sagst
seine kinder oder ihr zeit ihre kinder
auch nicht wirklich auf instagram nein
ich zeige meine kinder nicht aber ich
zeige auch relativ wenig ich habe ein
leben das gar nicht so vorzeige mäßig
ist auf instagram ist interessiert auch
kein hallo voller erfolg
interessierte blicks niemanden sachs
aber ist spaß beiseite ich würde auch
meine kinder nicht zeigen ich finde es
aber nicht dramatisch und zwar aus den
gründen die ihr auch genannt hat ich
finde es aber nicht dramatisch wenn sie
sagt auch menschlich packte jetzt ins
waschbecken und was die ab und hh und
man sieht die kinder bis zum opa
deswegen also ich finde einfach da
müssen wir die kirche im dorf lag aber
um uns geht es ja auch nicht es geht ja
wirklich um diejenigen die das die das
nicht unter kontrolle haben und die sich
nachweislich über das internet da eben
auch behandlungen betreiben die die ich
glaube das wisst ihr besser als mutter
ja aber unerträglich sind verstehe ich
total durch alt ist auch pädophile
natürlich hin ganz klar aber die gibt es
natürlich auch über alba und das ist
soll es jetzt nicht mindern aber ich
glaube dass man generell sich vielleicht
erst mal bevor man also ich oder wir
zeigen unsere kinder auch nicht im
internet oder bei instagram und und ich
mache das aus einem einfachen grund weil
ich aber nicht weiß ob die bock drauf
haben ein gericht das ist der einzige
grund ich denke gar nicht soweit
natürlich ist das sind dass nun weitere
gedanken die die man nicht zur seite
schieben darf aber trotzdem ein
hauptgrund ist wer weiß ob die bock
darauf haben und wenn sie lust darauf
haben wird das sowieso ein paar jahren
kommen weil die zeit geht so schnell und
die werden so ruckzuck würden wir uns
nämlich als eltern instagram ganz
schnell zurück in fünf bis zehn jahren
nämlich man da gibt es ganz andere
sachen und dann können die das von mir
aus gerne mache ich verurteile niemand
der der der die kinder bei instagram
reinstellt und und dass daran spaß hat
uns weiter um gottes willen das ist auch
eine schöne vorbereitung natürlich aber
ich finde man muss so ein bisschen auch
mal einfach für sich mal sich selbst
reflektieren und überlegen ist das okay
sein hätte nicht sein die entscheidung
bei unternehmen weiß ich nicht das war
unnötig so hat man kann es auch für sich
selber machen in seinem handy halten
aber das foto sollte nun an müssen
[Musik]